just before we get into the video let me
thank today's sponsor skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community for creators with thousands of
classes in design
business and more
now i've talked about skillshare a few
times on this channel and mentioned the
various courses and things
i've learned on that platform but maybe
you haven't got skillshare yet and
you're still
totally skillless and that's a great
shame because there are
thousands of classes on skillshare for
you to level up your skills in video
design
business social media just whatever
really or you could just take them from
nothing to something
me i've taken classes in video
production camera stuff youtubey stuff i
also want to squeeze out as much as
possible from my days so i took a course
by a guy called thomas frank who's also
a youtuber which was handy on getting
more stuff done in a day it's great
stuff
worth checking out if you're looking for
a specific recommendation
from me on that platform but yeah skull
share just go do it you'll like it it's
also free for two months if you use
our link below so that's pretty great
you support this show you support
skillshare it's a win-win and let's get
into it
it's a fact china is hot right now the
beijing regime's influence over the
world has never been as great as it is
today and the same applies to china's
fame and presence in global media and
you know what the person responsible for
all of that is this man
[Music]
xi jinping has become the chinese
president with the most power since the
fall of mao zedong he came to power in
2013 with two great promises
on the one hand to expand china's power
and influence
over the world and on the other to
consolidate the communist party's
political power that way the chinese
president seeks to end the widespread
belief that
economic development is always followed
by political transitions and democratic
processes
[Music]
but to achieve his goal and consolidate
his power xi jinping needs first to
remove
two large pebbles from his shoe two
pebbles he perceives as a threat to
china's cohesion and national identity
yes
i am talking about taiwan and hong kong
and it's precisely the second one hong
kong which we're going to be talking
about
in this video
as you probably all know hong kong is
currently experiencing the greatest
civil protest
since the end of british colonization
and they might also become the longest
protests the trigger
the extradition law
you see this law proposed by hong kong's
chief executive
carrie lam following beijing's
directives would allow for the
extradition of hong kong citizens to be
tried
and if applicable imprisoned in mainland
china in other words this proposed law
would recognize the validity of the
courts controlled by the chinese
communist party
and even though in the end after
pressure from the protesters the
proposed law was withdrawn it's a clear
example of how things
are working in hong kong
but why was this particular proposal the
last straw for the people of hong kong
what does carrie lam's proposal mean are
we witnessing a historical turning point
in the relationship between the former
colony and china
[Music]
the extradition law the straw that broke
the camel's back
that's right the extradition law is the
proverbial straw that broke the camel's
back
because don't think it all began with
this legislation not at all
beijing's interference in hong kong
politics and the promotion of
pro-chinese laws by hong kong
authorities which
actually emanates from the continental
regime itself the chinese regime
have been somewhat constant since the
united kingdom transferred hong kong
back to china in 1997. want an example
well check this out
let's go back to the year 2003 just six
years after its transfer to china the
hong kong executive proposed the
so-called national security law which
sought to ban and punish
pro-independence movements beijing was
seeking and i say seeking because the
law was repealed to shield its
sovereignty over the territory and stamp
out any scrap of opposition however it
didn't let a small obstacle get in its
way china ran into fierce opposition
from hong kong citizens which took to
the streets leading to the greatest
protest
in hong kong's history until now
[Music]
yes the protests of this year 2019 have
already
far exceeded those of 2003 and the truth
is that there are plenty of reasons why
[Music]
imagine that you live in a territory
with an independent economic system
guaranteed justice and a society with a
lot of freedom such as free access to
the internet and social networks and
suddenly a dictatorial regime with which
you don't identify
at all a regime where none of these
rights and freedoms exist and where
justice is controlled by a single party
seeks to impose a law that would allow
them to extradite you to be judged under
that regime with its conditions
what would you do
[Music]
discontents and anger seem far more than
justified wouldn't you think
after all the extradition law even
though it apparently doesn't
specifically mention political
opposition marks the end of hong kong's
model
and its autonomy because of course it
does don't tell me it's hard to imagine
a chinese court asking for the
extradition of a dissident or political
opponent for hong kong for any reason
right
[Music]
hong kong extradition laws a death
sentence for hong kong says exiled
bookseller lam wing ki
beijing will use this law to control
hong kong completely
freedom of speech will be lost in the
past the regime kidnapped its critics
like me
illegally with this law they will abduct
their critics
legally while the fact is that the
discontent is so great that according to
a recent study of the public opinion
program of the university of hong kong
rejection of china has never been as
strong among hong kong citizens
as it is now
[Music]
but that's not all the worst is the
general feeling that the hong kong
executive responds to china's interests
and not those
of its own local citizens
[Music]
and that's a problem in a territory
where citizens cannot change things
because the truth is that democracy
doesn't exist
in hong kong not all citizens are
allowed to vote and the government chief
executive himself is proposed by beijing
you see in a normal democratic and free
country if harula does badly if he or
she rules against the people's interests
or is discovered
favoring other interests people stop
voting for that person or that party and
then they can start undoing the bad
policies
however that can't happen here after
transferring the territory's sovereignty
to china the political system turned
into something very very similar to a
corporatist regime that
governs for the interests of two
powerful hands
on the one hand that of the chinese iron
fist and on the other the money-filled
hands of the great businessmen that
favor beijing
especially those of the great real
estate tycoons that have managed to form
an oligopoly where hong kong is nothing
more than a captive market that acts a
best service
surprised well he shouldn't be in fact
the hong kong political system
it feeds this model a lot
in fact we've already talked about this
in a previous video where we tell you
why hong kong has the most expensive
housing in the world
the point is that in hong kong the chief
executive the governmental leader is
elected by members of the election
committee which has about 1
200 people and who chooses those 1 200
representatives well to be honest it's
easier to start by counting those who
don't
vote that's the citizens we're talking
about a very complicated system in which
sectoral organizations religious leaders
business leaders unions and even
companies participate
it's all orchestrated to endorse china's
power
for example check out what's happening
with the agriculture sector which is
traditionally connected to beijing
despite only involving 0.1 percent of
hong kong's economy
farmers hold more weight in the election
committee than much
much more important sectors such as the
financial sector so as you can see
it's all very democratic right
[Music]
in fact the lack of democracy is the
real reason behind the current protests
and behind many
past protests because in spite of the
fact that democracy doesn't technically
exist
hong kong is and has been a regional
epicenter of political activism and
dissent against beijing for decades
[Music]
and the law of extradition was the last
straw in a process that is spelling the
end
of all those freedoms if you think about
it it's the most dramatic part of it
in hong kong we are facing a
dictatorship that wants to get its way
we're witnessing people who are used to
living in freedom and who are watching
that freedom
slip away every day and that explains
what comes next
[Music]
triple freedom downhill with no breaks
that's right in hong kong the three
freedoms are in free fall
economic individual and political
freedom all three have worsened since
china took over in 1997.
[Music]
and that has consequences on every level
especially in a place that has been
traditionally known for its scrupulous
respect for legal certainty and
institutional stability and that's
precisely why around 1
500 multinational companies have their
asian headquarters in hong kong however
all of this
may and badly not only in the political
field but also in the economic field
[Music]
china's continuous interference is in
many cases translating into
serious very serious violations of
several companies legal safety in the
economic field china's increased
its blackmailing of private companies so
they'll maintain a critical stance
against any movement that opposes
beijing that is if they don't want to
have any trouble staying in the big
chinese market
[Music]
that's what happened for example with
the hong kong airline cathay pacific
which suffered the consequences of not
being critical during the protests
against the extradition law and not
sufficiently controlling its workers
political expressions
[Music]
kathy pacific replaces chief executive
as china ups pressure over protests
kathy pacific staff speak of climate of
fear
cathay pacific employees say they fear
losing their jobs
they express support for pro-democracy
protesters in hong kong
some are considering bringing decoy
mobiles
with them in case their phones are
checked on arrival in the mainland
but no it doesn't end there
the repression of the business sector of
the productive sectors is even reaching
cases of
boycotts organized by the chinese
government itself through social
networks
and nobody's safe not even bubble tea
bubble tea brawl taiwan brand face
mainland boycott over hong kong gesture
worst of all we aren't even talking
about small isolated cases not at all
xi jinping knows that he runs a country
that has one of the most desired markets
for any company worth its salt an
overwhelmingly huge population a growing
middle class and consumer power that is
already at exorbitant levels to be in
business in china is to be close to
success and xi jinping
knows that this is something he can
leverage to politically press people by
using commerce and the business sector
and that obviously doesn't reassure any
company one misstep and it's all
downhill and also how are they going to
control their employees how can they
limit the freedom of expression of
others how can they attract
international talent with such
conditions
anyway it starts with bubble tea and it
ends with any company that doesn't want
to do what china wants and of course
this isn't just reprehensible it's
irresponsible
[Music]
china's attitude along with the blatant
protection of local oligarchs and the
submission of the local government
are ending hong kong's prosperity the
people of hong kong they feel like
they're not only losing their political
freedoms but also their own economic
well-being because if hong kong loses
its independence
it's legal certainty its neutrality
what's left the worst part is that hong
kong may simply
stop being hong kong
[Music]
so surely you now may understand why the
protests happened and why they've lasted
so long hong kong society it feels like
it's facing one of the last chances to
fight back that it's now or never but if
you want to know why xi jinping is so
interested in hong kong and why despite
all of this
china still needs this small territory
or stay tuned because we'll bring more
videos about hong kong in which we'll
explain these things and many others
very soon but it's your turn do you
think that the pressure from the people
of hong kong will help them regain their
political and individual freedoms will
china be able to squash hong kong's
languishing political freedom is this
the beginning of the end
of hong kong as we know it so i really
hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos also please do check out
skillshare two months for free there is
a link below
and as always thank you for watching
if you want to learn more about politics
and world affairs and hear some more of
my lovely voice
come check out the reconsider podcast
where we don't do the thinking for you
find reconsider at
www.reconsidermedia.com or on apple or
google play or your favorite podcast